MARCEL: Please help me
welcome Dr. Ivan Paulino-Lima.
[APPLAUSE]
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA: Thank you,
Marcel for the invitation.
I am really happy
to be here talking
a little bit about my
work on extremophiles
and how it relates to
human space exploration.
I'm a visiting scientist at
Universities Space Research
Association, which is an
organization with almost
50 years of existence.
It was established in 1969
in the age of space race.
So there was a demand for
scientists and engineers.
It was the age where
astronauts were bringing
rock samples from the moon.
NASA was developing many
different programs and research
projects.
And the USA played a very
important role in this mission
to NASA.
USRA is currently managing the
NASA post-doctoral program,
which is a one to three year
assignments for researchers
and is a very
competitive program.
And people from different
countries can apply as well.
It's open for foreign
nationals and US citizens.
I am an alumni
from this program.
I completed my post-doctoral
research at NASA last year
and then moved on to
the visiting scientist
position at USRA.
USRA also supports
STEM education.
We recently opened up a
center for STEM education
in Columbia, Maryland to
provide a place for students
to study and work on robotics.
The institute within
USRA that I am affiliated
is called Research Institute
for Advanced Computer Science.
And they have different
programs on computer science,
including quantum
computing, supercomputing,
cloud computing, and
one of the branches
that they are starting right
now is synthetic biology.
So they recently
established partnership
with NASA's Synthetic
Biology Initiative.
And the goal is to harness
engineer and biological systems
to further space
exploration and science
to search for life beyond Earth
and to improve life on Earth.
So NASA is leading these
efforts in synthetic biology
for space applications.
And the lab where I'm
working on at NASA Ames
is Lynn Rothschild's lab.
There is different
lines of research.
I'm currently involved in
the development, delivery,
and ground controls for
the PowerCell, payload
on the DLR CROPiS mission.
It's a partnership between NASA
and German space agency DLR.
And I'm also
continuing my NPP work
on extremophiles in radiation.
What really interested
me is the limits of life.
So the topic of my
research is to test
what are the limits of life
and working specifically
with extremophiles and looking
at radiation resistance.
So what are extremophiles?
Some people think that the
concept of extremophiles
is an anthropocentric concept.
But it's really not,
because these organisms,
they can thrive in
extreme conditions
where the conditions
in the environment
is close to the stability
for organic molecules.
So they're almost dying.
It's really difficult even
for them to live these places.
So it's not an
anthropocentric view.
And there are many
places on Earth
where we can find very
extreme conditions
and different examples of life
thriving in those environments.
Basically, whatever we
can find liquid water
being Antarctica or high
lakes in the Altiplanos,
in Hawaii, hydrothermal
systems, Yellowstone.
Wherever there is liquid water,
we can find examples of life
from microorganisms
that comprise
the vast majority of
life beings on Earth
and also a few other more
complex forms of life.
So the existence
of extremophiles
in such extreme
environments on Earth
make us think that it may be
possible for extremophiles
to exist in other places other
than Earth like planet Mars,
the moons of the giant
planets in our solar system,
and also more
recently, astronomy
is passing through a truly
scientific revolution
with the detection
of exoplanets.
So the scientists are
characterizing the conditions
on these planets
where are planets that
can be potentially habitable.
So there are places
in our neighborhood
in the galaxy where
we can in the future
potentially find
signals of life.
And this is the
cover of a document
that has been put together
and published last year.
It is a NASA
document introducing
the topic of astrobiology.
So astrobiology is a
scientific endeavor
that seeks to answer three basic
question-- the origin of life,
the distribution of
life, whether life
exists beyond Earth, and
also the future of life.
These are the three basic
questions of astrobiology.
And I think extremophiles is
one of the things that motivates
the scientists to create this
scientific endeavor called
astrobiology.
The discovery of
specifically thermophiles,
organisms that live in high
temperature environments,
back in the '60s and '70s was
the same age of the space race.
So everything collaborated
to the creation
of the concept of astrobiology.
And there are different
categories of extremophiles,
as you can see here in the
first column in this table.
And here in the
column to the right,
there is different
examples of organisms.
And as I said, I'm particularly
interested in the organisms
that can resist high doses
of radiation, both ionizing
and non-ionizing radiation.
And one of the most
studied biological models
for radiation resistance
is Deinococcus radiodurans.
There are other
biological models,
but Deinococcus is by
far the most studied,
the most characterized.
And I use these organisms as
a reference in my studies.
So why the study of radiation
and its effects on materials
in biology is important?
We know that radiation is a
major concern in space research
and space operations.
It impacts
satellites, especially
communications satellites,
that orbit geostationary
orbits of both of the
Earth's magnetic fields.
But it also is a concern for
the International Space Station,
for low Earth orbit
satellites, and also
for human missions beyond
Earth's magnetic field,
like missions to the Moon and
missions to Mars and so on.
And it is really a concern
for NASA's journey to Mars.
NASA is currently developing
a very solid program
to send humans to Mars in the
next two or three decades.
And this graph shows different
radiation limits for,
just as an example, astronauts
spending six months on ISS
are exposed to 75
millisieverts of radiation.
This is a unit of
absorbed radiation.
And this is much more than the
annual limits for a Department
of Energy radiation worker.
And a trip to Mars will
subject any astronaut
to a dose of 466
millisievert as measured
by an instrument
on the Mars Science
Laboratory, the last big robot
that NASA sent to Mars in 2011.
So it's really a limiting
factor for the expansion
of the presence of
humans in space.
And it's very difficult to
shield against radiation.
It's very expensive to bring
heavy material to orbit.
So luckily, we have
examples in nature
where we can find organisms
dealing and coping
with radiation much
better than humans
and other biological models.
And what are the effects
of radiation on biology?
We know genetic information
is stored on the DNA molecule.
And when damage caused
by radiation affects DNA,
it is a problem.
The cells have the
whole DNA machinery
to repair those damages.
In the case of
high-energy radiation,
it can cause strand breaks
on DNA, double strands
and single-strand breaks.
And that's the most
severe type of damage
for most of the cells.
And some of these organisms are
very resistant to radiation.
They are specializing in
repairing this type of damage,
strand breaks on the DNA.
Just to give you an
idea of the importance
of the works on DNA repair.
Last year, the Nobel
Prize for chemistry
was awarded through
these three researchers
working on the mechanistic
studies of DNA repair.
And so most of the
knowledge about DNA repair
came from the studies
of these groups.
But everything we know
about radiation resistance
comes from things that we can
work in the laboratory, things
that we can cultivate, isolate,
and work in the laboratory,
because we have to
create survival curves.
That's the most
traditional way to measure
radiation resistance.
So this graph shows
different survival curves
for different
organisms, including
human cells and some other
examples of very sensitive
organisms to radiation.
And these are different
types of radiation.
X-rays, it's ionizing
radiation, very high energy.
And then UV-C, a little
bit lower energy,
and it also causes
damage to the DNA.
And desiccation is also
an environmental parameter
that causes the
same type of damage,
so it correlates with
the damage of radiation,
and it's sometimes is used as a
proxy for radiation resistance.
There are also
other forms of life
that are resistant to radiation
like these ones-- amoeba,
and fungi, rotifers, insects.
Some biological models are also
very resistant to radiation
if they survive those higher
than 1,000 grays of ionizing
radiation.
Radiation resistance is
a widespread phenotype
with representative organisms
from the three domains of life.
And its a multi-factor
phenotype.
So there are different
things contributing
for radiation resistance.
As an example,
Deinococcus radiodurans,
the biological model for
radiation resistance,
shares a large part of its gene
pool with Thermus thermophilus.
And yet Thermus thermophilus
is very sensitive,
while Deinococcus is very
resistant to radiation.
So clearly, there are
physiological factors
affecting radiation resistance.
So one of these factors,
maybe the most important
physiological factor
that factor that
contributes for
radiation resistance,
is the accumulation
of manganese.
Actually, it's the ratio between
manganese intracellularly.
This was demonstrated
almost 12 years ago
by the group of Michael Daly.
They are survival curves for
different biological models.
And if you pass a line
through the level of radiation
that kills 90% of
the population,
this is a logarithmic scale.
So this is the
dose that kills 90%
of a population of Deinococcus.
And these are the values for
each one of these survival
curves.
If you transferred this to
this graph here on the right
and try to correlate with
intracellular manganese-to-iron
ratio, you can see there
is this general trend
being sensitive
organisms, they have
a low ratio between manganese
and iron intracellularly.
And the resistant ones
has have high intraceullar
manganese-to-iron ratio.
And this suggested actually
that maybe proteins also
play-- the damage to proteins
is also critical for recovery
after radiation.
And that's what they
demonstrated a few years ago,
irradiating total proteins
for sensitive organisms
here on the left and resistant
organisms to the right.
So they used a
compound called DNPH
to reveal the presence
of carbonyl groups
in those proteins.
And when they are
heavily radiated,
all the proteins become
oxidated and generate
this carbonyl groups.
And it's revealed here.
And Deinococcus radiodurans
and other resistant organisms,
even with a large dose of
radiation of 4 kilograys,
their proteins do not
oxidate and remain active
and are able to repair
the damage on the DNA.
And this is just a
translation of these data.
So organisms that are very
sensitive to radiation, there's
a lot of carbonyl groups
formed after radiation.
And the ones that are
resistant, the proteins
remain active because
they're not oxidated.
And based on all
these data, this
is the current model of
extreme radiation resistance.
We can think of
this graph as two.
We can divide this graph into
two parts-- sensitive cells
on the top and resistant
cells at the bottom.
So when a cell is
exposed to radiation,
there are direct effects and
indirect effects on the genome
and throughout the cell.
If the cell cannot repair this
damage, it leads to cell death.
There are indirect effects which
is the generation of shower
of free radicals, so
hydroxyl radicals, hydrogen
peroxide, and superoxide.
The hydroxyl
radicals, the damage
caused by this type
of free radical
is uniformly distributed
cellular damage.
So every component of
the cell are damaged
by this type of free radical.
And these two are more
specific for proteins.
And in the case of
sensitive cells,
these proteins get oxidated
and cannot repair the damage
in the DNA.
And the cell dies.
In the case of
resistant cells, they
accumulate a lot of manganese,
manganese-to-iron ratio.
And these manganese
forms complexes
with small peptides and
nucleosides inside the cell.
And then it ends up
quenching and scavenging
the effects of these free
radicals on the cells.
And then the proteins
remain active
and are able to repair
cellular functions.
And the cells remain alive.
But what are these
manganese complexes?
Manganese is a
transitional model
that is able to combine
with different molecules,
especially small metabolites
like nucleosides, amino acids,
and peptides, and
aryl phosphates.
And these complexes can
then scavenge, protect,
act like a shield against
these small free radicals
in the cell.
And there are some
research already
being done by
Michael Daly's group
using these
intracellular manganese
complexes in human cells.
We can see here
human cells treated
with [INAUDIBLE]
manganese pyrophosphate
is significantly more resistant
than the known treated control.
So this is a very
interesting line of research
that could benefit future
astronauts going to Mars.
But that brings the question of
whether Deinococcus radiodurans
is is the last frontier
of radiation resistance.
All of this is based on
Deinococcus radiodurans
and a few other
biological models.
And the question we
have is whether there
are other biological
models available in nature
that we don't know yet.
So maybe other organisms
could accumulate higher levels
of manganese, may have
more efficient DNA repair,
and may produce antioxidant
secondary metabolites
that are more higher level
of these metabolites.
Or maybe these metabolites
can be better applied
to human cell lineages.
So this motivated us to
go through extreme places
on Earth, actually deserts,
enriched in manganese,
so combining the
dessication factor
and the manganese availability.
So I've been through the
Sonoran Desert in Arizona
in a collaboration
with a company called
American Manganese.
They collaborated with
providing soil to us.
And also I went to
the Atacama Desert
to collect some sand
samples there and also
a few samples from NASA's
Ames campus as a control.
So this is a picture of
myself collecting samples
in the Atacama.
And I don't think
it's very easy for you
to see the blue
atmosphere here, which
is the best indication
that it's not Mars,
because a picture of that
resembles a lot of Mars.
You cannot see any
green, any grass.
There is no indication of
life in this environment.
It's hard to breathe.
We spent two hours in this
environment, collected
a few samples, and then we were
ready to go back to Antofagasta
where we were staying.
So it's a very, very,
very extreme environment.
It is considered a Martian
analog, because of its dryness.
Sometimes the dryness
of the Atacama Desert
is even higher than
similar situations
on Mars, some places on Mars.
So it is really an
extreme environment.
So after bringing back
to NASA Ames the samples,
we exposes these samples
to different doses
of UV-C radiation, which can be
generated by a fluorescent lamp
without this white coating.
So it's a very reliable,
very cheap method
to isolate radiation
resistant organisms.
And after a period
of incubation,
we isolated the colonies that
grew after the largest doses
and performed survival curves,
characterized the extracellular
and intracellular
manganese-to-iron
ratio through ICPMS and did some
optical and electro-microscopy
studies.
So we were surprised to see
high diversity on samples coming
from the Atacama Desert
compared to samples
from the manganese
mine in Arizona
and also very low diversity
of radiation resistant
isolates from NASA
Ames as expected.
But this was surprising,
the high diversity
of very resistant organisms
through UV-C radiation.
And we also compared true
methods, a filtration method,
where you elute the soil
particulates in a buffer
and then filter to get
rid of the soil particles.
But of course, you lose
a lot of the diversity,
and that's exactly what
this graph is showing here.
Most of the organisms
obtained by this method
was represented by
Bacillus and Sporosarcina
and Planomicrobium.
And so the sprinkling
method is the best one
to generate a higher diversity
of resistant organisms.
And then after isolating
these organisms,
we cultivated them
individually, and exposed
to another round of radiation,
and generated this continuum
of radiation resistance compared
to Deinococcus radiodurans
up there, which survives
100% to this dose and E. coli
at the bottom here.
So we now have this
microbiological culture
collection with
radiation-resistant organisms
with different levels
of radiation resistance.
And then we looked into the
extracellular and intracellular
manganese ratio and
compared to the survival
of these organisms.
So this graph shows that the
extracellular manganese-to-iron
ratio, the availability
of these metals
does not determine the
survival of organisms
from this environment,
but actually,
the intracellular
manganese-to-iron ratio,
there is a trend towards high
intracellular manganese-to-iron
ratio and radiation
resistance as was demonstrated
by Michael Daly's group
for laboratory strains
using gamma irradiation.
So this we demonstrated
for the first time
that this is also true
for environmental isolates
and for another
type of radiation,
which is UV-C radiation.
And this happens
because the inputs,
the uptake of manganese,
occurs as an active mechanism.
So the cells needs need to have
molecular mechanisms to uptake
manganese from the environment.
So the availability of
manganese in the environment
does not determine
radiation resistance.
But those that can accumulate
high manganese-to-iron ratio,
they will have a better chance
to be radiation resistant.
So then we did survival
curves with the most radiation
resistant ones.
And we actually found one
organism more resistant
than Deinococcus
radiodurans, which
is this one in red
compared to Deinococcus
radiodurans in blue.
So the question
whether Deinococcus
is the last frontier?
Probably not.
Probably there are other
organisms more resistant
than Deinococcus in
nature and that we just
didn't discover yet.
This is another organism
called Geodermatophilus.
It produces a black pigment.
It forms cell clumps.
That's why the survival curve
seems like a broken curve here.
So that means that cells
outside of the clumps
get inactivated faster than
the ones inside the core.
But these ones, it's
truly more resistant,
because it doesn't
form cell clumps,
and it produces a very
light pink pigment.
But when we did radiation
with gamma rays,
Deinococcus is still
much better at repairing
double strand breaks
and the damage caused
by high-energy radiation.
But still, the discovery
of these organisms
and a few others very
resistant to radiation,
represents a new
front in efforts
to harness mechanisms
of radiation resistance
from nature.
So this is just a picture of
both organisms, Hymenobacter
here to the left,
so clearly showing
that doesn't form cell clumps.
And this is Geodermatophilus
representing
a more passive mechanism
of radiation protection,
not resistance,
not active repair.
But it produces a black pigment.
And it forms cell clumps.
That's why it's very resistant.
This is a picture
of Hymenobacter
grown on a plate showing
the light pink pigment.
So we think there are active
mechanisms of DNA repair going
on here that is very interesting
to study and understand.
And these organisms also
have some internal vesicles
that may or may not play a
role on radiation resistance.
We don't know if this
is viral particles that
could have DNA repair
enzymes like polymerases.
We recently published a
draft genome of this organism
in "Genome Announcements"
earlier this year.
So the information
is right there.
And we are currently
investigating
what type of DNA
repair genes it has
and what type of
pigment production
it does, internal cellular
metabolites, and so on.
An interesting spin off from
my post-doctoral research
was a collaboration with
astronomers from the Max Planck
Institute now at
Cornell University.
Lisa Kaltenegger is the director
of the Carl Sagan Center
for Studies of Exoplanets.
And her PhD student at
the time, Siddarth Hegde,
is now her post-doc researcher,
collaborated with us
at NASA Ames.
And Lynn Rothschild provided
the guidance and interpretation
of the data.
Basically, we created
artificial microbiomats
to measure absolute
reflectance spectra,
because up till last
year, most of the data set
about reflectance spectra was
about phototrophic organisms,
so green stuff,
microalgae, algae,
and plants and just a few
heterotrophic microbes
with different
color of pigments.
And in our study, we opened
the spectrum of the diversity
of pigments analyzed.
We now have a databank of
137 different organisms,
different pigments, spectra.
This is how the data looks like.
This is a Geodermatophilus
strain, the one that
produced the black pigment.
That's why the reflectance on
the visible region is very low.
And there is a lot of reflection
on the near infrared region,
which is a very interesting
region for astronomers.
And now, this data
set, this catalog,
is available online
and open to the public.
Other researchers can
contribute other data.
And we hope that this
spectra of different pigments
will help astronomers.
It's actually already
helping astronomers
to analyze data from exoplanets,
searching for a biosignature.
So when astronomers combine
different information
from the gravity of the planets
and distance from the sun
if the planet is available,
with this type of information,
they can at least
suggest whether there
is any potential
biosignature on exoplanets.
And with all this
research on extremophiles,
how does this relate to
human space exploration?
So we know that there are
different industries on Earth
right now using
extremophiles for production
of different things from food,
biofuels, materials, and so on.
And we think that
all this capability
will be transferred to
Mars during the human space
missions in the future.
And we are currently
developing the science
that will enable
this goal that NASA
has to send humans to Mars
within the next two or three
decades.
And so one way we
think about it is
there are organisms on Earth
that it's very cheap, very
reliable, very
easy to cultivate,
which are the cyanobacteria.
These are bacteria that
can do photosynthesis.
So it has chlorophyll inside.
They only need solar energy, and
water, and a few micronutrients
that are all available on Mars
already as part of its surface.
And we can cultivate this
type of cyanobacteria on Mars
and then generate
organic compounds that
can be used by heterotrophic
organisms, other types
of bacteria that
can then produce
the biomaterials,
biocompounds, and everything
that the astronauts will
need for their mission.
So this is a picture that
has been put together
by our collaborator,
Cyprien Verseux.
This is a person who is spending
one year on a Mars simulation
mission on Hawaii
in a Martian dome.
He's going to leave
the dome next week.
And he's doing research there.
It is a crew of six people.
He's one of them.
He collaborates
in our laboratory.
He collects samples.
And he's doing research
with cyanobacteria there
and has some very
interesting results.
So we think that
a Martian colony
in the future in the
next, I don't know,
several decades
or centuries, this
is how it will look like, a
cyanobacteria pond generating
food and primary products
that will enter a production
chain for different
applications-- biofuels,
nutrients, and so on.
And we think that
synthetic biology--
I think the same way
that astronomy is passing
through a revolution with
the detection of exoplanets,
biology is also passing
through a similar revolution
on the same scale through
synthetic biology.
There is a lot of
synthetic biology tools
to engineer organisms in
a much more efficient way
than 10 years ago.
And these will be
crucial to improve
the performance of
any organisms that we
will support the mission
of astronauts on Mars.
And this is a more
complex picture
of the same type
of Martian colony.
I just would like you to
imagine an astronaut on Mars
in a very long mission
to Mars getting sick.
And there is no
precise diagnostic.
laboratories there.
There is no hospitals.
And one thing that
can be done is
if there is any sequence or
any type of facility that
can analyze human
materials like blood,
and then send this information
through radio frequency
to Earth, then on Earth we
have a lot of hospitals,
a lot of laboratories
to work on a solution,
provide vaccine
information, and then
this information can be
sent back to Mars and then
whatever compound that
is needed can be produced
on Mars and then people
on Earth contributing
to improve the performance
of astronauts on Mars.
So this is a reality that
is envisioned by NASA.
And that's something that we
are working with small steps
right now.
But it's something that we
envision for the future.
But before doing
all that, we have
to know whether synthetic
biology tools that
are used nowadays
on Earth will work
the same way in other worlds,
in different gravity levels.
And that's what these
mission is addressing.
We have an experiment
called PowerCells
on a mission called EuCROPiS.
EuCROPiS stands for Euglena
Combined Regenerative Organic
Food Production in Space.
It's a very long acronym.
This is, as I said, is a
partnership between NASA
and DLR.
And they have their own
experiments with Euglena.
And also they're going
to grow tomatoes in space
in a satellite in orbit
for the first time.
Last year, astronauts
were able to grow lettuce.
There are other
things being produced.
So in small steps, we are
creating our little crops
in orbit.
So the idea of this project
is to perform two experiments
that we call PowerCell.
This first one is
basically a co-culture.
We're using a strain
of Anabaena that
has been genetically
engineered in our lab
to produce and secrete sucrose
and release to the culture
medium so that other organisms,
a second organism, Bacillus
subtilis, which is a
widespread biological model
used in different
industries, we will
be able to use this
resource and then
produce different types
of biomaterials-- food
and compounds and so on.
And we're going to do these in
a microfluidics device, four
rows of 12 wells.
We are currently in the final
step of sampling the payloads.
These payloads will
be sent to Germany
where it will be integrated
to the satellite.
And it will be
launched next year
from Vandenberg Launch Facility
in Southern California.
The second experiment is
genetic transformation,
which is a basic tool for
every microbiology laboratory
on Earth.
That's going to
be the first time
that these type of experiments
will be performed in space
in four different
gravity levels,
because we are going
to be able to control
the spinning of the
satellites to simulate
the gravity of Mars, and
moon, and also microgravity.
And then the fourth
gravity level
is our ground
controls at NASA Ames.
And then you can
think of why focusing
on space rather than
the other problems
that we already have on Earth.
I think besides all the
technological heritage provided
by space exploration,
there is one thing that
is more important than all
that is the human spirit.
And Konstantin
Tsiolkovsky, which
is the father of astronautics,
the Russian father
of astronautics, used
to say that the Earth is
the cradle of humanity.
But one cannot live
in a cradle forever.
And once someone
asked me what we
are going to do with the cradle
after we leave the cradle.
I answered that we
will do the same thing
that with our own
cradles in our homes.
We will pass it on to
the new generations.
We will take good
care of this cradle.
And Earth will always be
the birthplace of humanity.
And we will never forget
that we were born here.
Whatever happens in
the future I think
we don't want to give up
the dream of expanding
the presence of humans in
space in reality, which may
mean going to other planets.
And the benefit of
going to other planets
is also avoiding
large-scale catastrophies
that could extinct humans.
So it's really a
matter of survival
if you think on
long-term scales.
We know for a fact that the
Sun in 4.5 billion years
will expand.
And there's going
to be no more Earth.
So at some point
at least we will
have to address this question.
And the best way to predict
the future is build the future.
That's exactly what
we're doing now.
And I think if we
think carefully and do
it the right way, I think that's
the vision that NASA shares.
And that's the future
that lies ahead
of us, starting from
a small step, which
is Martian colonization
in the next few decades
or the next few centuries.
And in the bigger scale, we
know that almost all stars
that we see in the
night sky today
is actually not a single star.
It's a planetary system with
planets orbiting around them.
So we know that many
of these planets
are potentially habitable
so our new destinations
for future generations.
We currently don't
have any technology
to go to other stars,
even the nearest
one is 4.5, 4.6 light
years from Earth,
which is there is no
possibility to go there
with current technology.
But that doesn't mean
that it won't happen.
There's a lot of technology
that exists today
that we even didn't think of.
But I think this simple
fact of recognizing
that there are places in our
neighborhood in the galaxy that
can be potentially habitable.
It brings a sense of hope
for humanity and also
responsibility to take
care of our planet
and the other
destinations that humanity
will have in the future.
And I think this is the vision
that the scientific community
shares.
And it is very fascinating
time to be a scientist,
to be an engineer working
at NASA with leading
all these efforts.
So I think we are
privileged to live
in such time of scientific and
technological breakthroughs.
And with that, I just
would like to acknowledge
my team and the international
collaborators that
have been playing a role
on my research and also,
the facilities and
institutions that
funded and provided the
conditions for me to develop
my research.
And I thank you all for your
time, for your attention,
and I'd like to open for
questions that you guys have.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I believe
it's the case
that on all of the
missions to Mars, the stuff
we send there is very
carefully sterilized so
that if we do find
life on Mars, we
know that it's indigenous,
not something that we sent up
there.
At what point do
we give up on that?
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA:
So this is a matter
of debate, actually, for all
these missions, human missions
to Mars.
We know that any
human mission to Mars
will eventually
contaminate Mars.
That we know.
This is something
that we know for sure.
And I think in the past, the
protocols for sterilization
of spacecraft, they were not
as rigid as they are today.
We think that some of the
earlier missions sent to Mars
may have carried some
bio-burden on Mars.
But we think that
this bio-burden
won't do anything there, because
the environment is so hostile.
There's no water,
a lot of radiation.
It's very hard to think of
any type of growth there.
So I think it's
currently being decided.
It is an ethical question
if we have the right
to go to another planet knowing
that contamination will happen.
And it is interesting
to note that the most
interesting places
to detect life, which
are the aquifers, places
where there is more water,
are also the best places for
humans to go there and make
use of those resources.
But we are still
debating, actually,
what are the implications
of contaminating Mars,
the extent we accept that.
This is a matter of debate.
We recently had a meeting,
I think last year at NASA,
to debate that.
It was called Planetary
Protection on knowledge gaps
that we have in this area.
So I think we cannot give up
on exploration just with fear
of contaminating stuff, because
if this is a matter of our own
survival, then I think it puts
a lot of weight on the ethical
debate.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there is a fungi
inside the Chernobyl reactor.
I was just wondering how
the radiation tolerance
of that organism compares to
the ones that you were analyzing
and are the
mechanisms different?
There's a lot of [INAUDIBLE] for
energy production potentially.
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA: Yeah, this
is very interesting actually.
The question is
about fungi that was
found inside a nuclear reactor.
It's not clear how they
resist to such high levels
of radiation.
I think the method to determine
their radiation resistance
it's not quite similar
to what I've shown here.
But I would rate these organisms
as very, very resistant,
very interesting.
They started to look at these
organisms five years ago.
And they're still
characterizing.
It seems that it can convert
the energy of gamma rays
to a usable form of
energy after there
is some effect inside the cell.
It's very interesting to know
that there are organisms even
living within nuclear reactors.
But I think they would be as
resistant or very close to what
I've shown here to Deinococcus
and all the other organisms.
AUDIENCE: You showed a
curve of the pigments,
and it had two very
distinct drops.
What's up with that?
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA: Those are
water absorption features
on these spectra.
And these features we
observe for all samples,
because they all have water.
And that's something
that astronomers
will observe if there's any life
form detected in exoplanets.
So these are just
water molecules.
And if we do the
experiment long enough,
the samples get dehydrated and
those features get extinct.
So these are just
water absorption lines.
AUDIENCE: So
maganese-containing compounds
is not the only
antioxidant then obviously.
Any reasons this seems
to be particularly chosen
for these bacteria?
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA:
Well, of course,
any organisms that are
resistant to radiation
have to have
genetic information.
So the basic machinery to repair
the DNA needs to be there.
And the information needs
to be encoded by DNA.
But I think late '90s,
beginning of the 2000s,
people started to think of other
factors, physiological factors.
And they tested different
things, different compounds,
different metals, different
nutrients that could
affect radiation resistance.
And then they started to see
that organisms that accumulate
high manganese had
these trend of being
resistant to radiation.
And just in the
past few years, that
has been elucidated that these
manganese complexes helps
to protect the proteins
against oxidation.
And then the proteins
remain active
and can do the DNA repair.
And in fact,
Deinococcus radiodurans
is specialized in
double-strand break repair.
Compared to other organisms, it
lacks a few genes of DNA repair
to oxidative damage like
UV-A and UV-B generates
a lot of oxidative stress.
And Deinococcus is as
resistant as E. coli.
It is sensitive
to UV-A and UV-B,
because it's more specialized
for double-strand break
resistance.
So that's what
motivates us to seek
for a more complete set of
genes on an organism that
has a more complete set
of genes or strategies
to survive high
doses of radiation
and also to
understand better how
we can transfer this capability
to humans in the future.
AUDIENCE: You showed mechanisms
for getting radiation
resistance through
gathering of radicals
and of keeping repair
mechanisms alive.
But are there any
speculations about mechanisms
that go directly to the DNA?
Or is that DNA damaged
from the radiation just a
given and has to be dealt with?
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA:
So the question
is about the radiation
effects on the DNA.
So gamma rays, I think the
most severe type of damage
on the DNA caused by
high-energy radiation
like gamma rays is
double-strand breaks,
but it also generates
a lot of free radicals
and oxidative
stress in the cells.
But I think what determines
the survival or cell
death is the accumulation
of this type of damage.
Even Deinococcus will die if
the dose is high enough, because
of this type of damage that
is not trivial to repair.
It involves a
protein called RecA
to recruit a whole
machinery of other enzymes
to repair this damage.
But it's very interesting
to know that Deinococcus
does that within four hours.
The genome can be
broken up to 200 pieces.
And it will re-assemble
these pieces
in the right position in the
right sequence within four
hours.
So it's very amazing
how efficient
is the DNA repair mechanism
from Deinococcus radiodurans.
AUDIENCE: So as a general rule,
if you have higher radiation
rates in particular, does that
cause higher mutation rates,
which then makes organisms
more easily evolve
to radiation resistance?
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA: It
depends on the organism.
In the case of
Deinococcus radiodurans,
since they are very efficient
at repairing DNA damages,
it's hard to get mutants for
Deinococcus radiodurans, which
doesn't mean that
it's impossible.
Actually, there are ways of
getting mutants of Deinococcus.
But other organisms that are
less efficient at doing repair
would be easier to get
mutants from radiation.
That's what has been used I
think in 30, 40 years ago.
That was the main method to
generate mutants, just boost
an organism though radiation.
And then select whatever grows.
And you would isolate mutants.
I did it myself for my
undergraduate research.
So I generated a lot
of mutants in the fungi
that I was studying there.
AUDIENCE: We have
seen a lot of progress
in space exploration
mainly in rocket
and recently a lot of private
initiative, mainly SpaceX.
Is this type of
research a blocker
for getting into Mars
safely, because you
seem like the extreme
radiation will
be exposed for a long time?
Are we waiting for
this type of work
in order to launch
the next rocket?
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA:
No, actually not.
I think people-- this
private initiatives are
contributing actually to develop
the field of space exploration.
I think with current technology
with good current knowledge
about radiation resistance,
we will eventually
go to Mars accepting the risks.
But it would be nice to
come up with strategies
to improve radiation
resistance of astronauts
by using synthetic biology,
genetic engineering, and so on.
But it by no means is stopping.
I think it will
happen definitely even
with current technology
and knowledge.
And this is one
of the reasons why
I believe that the
human mission to Mars
will happen within
our generation.
I think we will be able to
see that, one more reason
to be thankful to live
in this exciting moment.
I'm not that old.
But I hear this story
about sending humans
to Mars for a long time.
But now, I believe that many
things are being put together.
Technology is far faster.
Rockets are being developed.
All of this synthetic biology
revolution is happening.
So I really believe now that
within the next two or three
decades we will see the
first humans on Mars.
And I hope there will not be
people saying that humans never
went to Mars.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
IVAN PAULINO-LIMA:
OK, thank you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]